[Music]
[Applause]
everybody so the whole talk is going to
be on the whiteboard I'm going to say
things too if you can't see or hear
something yell at me I probably won't be
paying attention to you so yeah
what so yeah so I implemented it it's
not great I don't recommend anyone read
it but I'll put the link on here and
I'll write it in two different colors
it's a link
that's my name that's rmq you'll know
what are in queue as soon yeah so I work
at Toki check we build awesome databases
if you want to come work for us talk to
you later
we're hiring a bunch of stuff like sales
marketing QA tech support engineers
product managing come talk to me weak to
hire people I'm an engineer they're two
of the founders there are four founders
but two of them wrote this paper one of
them was my professor I'm going to
basically give the lecture that he gave
in one of the classes that I prepare
which is about we all see a problem so
what is the LCA problem stands for
lowest common ancestor so we're going to
talk about trees so let's draw a tree
okay there's a tree the lowest common
ancestor problem is to pre-process a
tree so that you can answer queries of
the form find me the lowest common
ancestor for nodes U and V let's call
this U let's call this V the lowest
common ancestor for those two nodes it
is this one so the problem we want to
solve is pre-processing a tree in a
certain amount of time call that so that
we can answer queries of this form using
that pre-process data structure in you
know G amount of time I'll use this
notation I'm gonna use Big O notation if
you're not comfortable with that raise
your hand now and I will do like 30
seconds on big up ok Big O notation is
how we analyze algorithms when you want
to talk about how fast something runs
you talk about Big O notation the
formalism comes from calculus but
basically what you need to know is if
you have an input of size n then the
running time is going to be some
function event so if you have an input
that is 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 nodes your
running time is going to be a function
of the number 8 and we talked about Big
O of n to basically get rid of a bunch
of complexity from describing this so we
talked about those that are order N or
linear time algorithms which means are
going to process everything roughly once
maybe you process everything twice but
you're not going to process everything a
number of times equal to the size of the
problem we talk about things that are
Kahn
things that take 1 2 3 4 operations but
it doesn't depend on the size of the
problem you talked about things that are
log n which means you're usually doing
some kind of binary search we talk about
things that are quadratic or and which
means you know maybe for it I know we
need to look at every other node so
we're gonna do any things for this node
and things for this note and things for
this note and so on so we have n times n
in that sense where if you have any more
problems which the other big Oh things
that I write down later
shout out again so the N is the number
of nodes in the tree yes so and here is
the input size than the birth note
signature is n I'm going to talk about
pre-processing in F of n time and
answering queries in G at that time and
so you can imagine you know if you do
know preprocessor this is its order 1 it
was a constant time and then this will
be you know if you just given the tree
up front every time how fast can you
answer the query so why do we care about
most common ancestor
anyone want your guess is compression
network grabbing lots of reasons you
might want to know what the lowest
common ancestor of tune though it says
just real quick like for compilers if
each new is a basic block maybe you have
some some variable that's used here and
it's used here you want to see like how
far up in the tree in the tree of basic
blocks do I have to lift this in order
to you know make it
yeah yeah so that's cool
this is a very old problem it was first
posed in 1973 it was solved optimally in
1984 and then this paper was written to
2000 this actual algorithm was written
in 93 but it was really complicated 2000
paper is really cool it's really easy to
read hopefully most of you didn't read
it because it's more fun if you don't
know what's coming the paper in 2000 was
written by my professor and his friend
who founded our company they won some
fancy award for it it's been cited like
a ton of times and it's really cool so
I'm gonna talk about the assumptions
made about the maximum number of
children where the extent to which the
tree is balanced nope it's just a tree
it's really a tree in the graph there
sense so there's no cycles and you have
to identify a root but there's no other
restrictions yeah this can go on down
here as much as you want
there's no balancing anything what's
another dominant one there yes yeah so
the no second is restricts that
so what I'm going to describe only works
for a tree you can extend it to a dag
the authors did in a later paper that
I'm not going to talk about so yeah
anyway so yeah so formally the LCA
problem is picture notes find the the
node farthest from our roof that is a
parent of both those and so we're going
to pre-process a tree to do that so
let's stop talking about LCA and let's
talk about different
all right okay that's their down so
let's our power and q RM q stands for
range minimum query so this is a problem
where you're given an array and I
conveniently wrote out an example right
here
so you have an array it's got integer
elements
now the range minimum query problem is
to again the pre processes visited
pretty process this array so that you
can answer questions of the form given
two indexes I and J find me the element
in between them that is this most so in
a range we're gonna find the minimum
element for the query and we write this
they put a subscript on it that we like
to write that anyway this is a different
problem
you can pre-process an array and time f
of n where n is the number of elements
in the array and you can answer a query
in x and g event that should be familiar
so why am i talking about this this is
about the LCA problem it turns out we
can take an LCA problem and turn it into
a arrangement where a problem this is a
really cool technique called reduction
if you haven't seen this before good
because it's awesome thing you should
learn about it so how do you do this the
way we're going to do this is by
constructing what's called an Euler tour
which is kind of like a depth-first
search so given the tree
I got the same tree before
so this is your tree you label these
notes just to talk about them
actually let me label those will be more
interesting if I relay below this is
gonna be C okay cool yeah actually those
are prime all right so we're gonna label
the bread first of all we're not
traverse the street at first so what is
it oiler tour boiler tour is what you
get when you start at the root are you
doing you do a depth first search with
the tree so you go down to B then you go
down to D but the interesting thing is
when you come back up from visiting a
subtree you visit the parent again so
we're going to visit B again David on TV
then teeth and a CF c g CH c and then
back to a so every internal node is
going to appear twice every leaf node
it's gonna appear once and what do you
get this what's right now a B D and then
a again C f/c gch okay
and then a CNA okay so I'm making the
right out of my tree I guess I could do
our on keel on it so what we're going to
do here is now that we've got this Euler
tour we're going to take our - to query
notes let's say there we're trying to
solve LCA of B so we're going to find B
it up in the Euler tour let's say we
pick this one and this one well we want
to do LCA on that well let's pretend we
can't compare letters because they're
letters they're not numbers so what do
we do here
[Music]
sure yeah so distance from the root
let's try that so a is zero right aims
the release its distance from the root
is 0 B is 1 D is 2 B is 1 again right so
we're computing this array of the level
of the elements in the Euler tour where
you know so depth down the tree so I'm
just going to go ahead and fill this out
okay so now I've turned these into
numbers so I can compare them which
means I can do our cue ago so okay all
the range minimum query of this range is
zero which corresponds to a that's the
root if this was my actual query well
that's the right answer
okay cool does that work for any
selection of the unit yes why business I
can say because it's kind of shrink wrap
so you can't go any higher out doing the
in the in between the common ancestor
will always be higher up and then the
shrink wrapping of that shape right so
there's there's two parts to mystery so
one part is the node the node that
actually is the lowest common ancestor
will always appear between any two
appearances of your query nodes in the
Euler tour note that B appears twice but
whichever when I pick a is between B and
F then the reason for that is well you
know I'm going to visit be either once
or twice if I visit it twice well let's
just consider the second time I visit
because the other what's up visit name
three times
I'm sorry three times yes visit multiple
times right so let's just take the last
time I see it right the last time I see
it is when I'm leaving its subtree I'm
going back up to the parent somewhere
else so let's talk about so B is the
child that happens to be to the left so
let's talk about the last time I see B
and let's talk about the first time I
see half because the stuff that's
between those needs to include their
minimum query and if you know the next
time I see if it will also include the
same notes so the last time I see B and
the first time I see yeah well the last
time I see be going up so I'm going up
to its parent and the first time I see F
I'm coming down from it's apparent so if
they share an ancestor because of the
way the Euler tour is constructed I have
to visit all of their ancestors
somewhere in between the last time I see
B in the first time I see yeah
is that cool
so let's pretend that you know which
order there are and then you can flip
them if one is to the left the other
ones to the right you can do this I just
you know you know we're in time you do
an inorder traversal of the nodes you
can calculate their indexes and that if
an index is higher than the other you
flow so yes you can you can figure out
which one switch so what's the other
part
proof right you can't visit anything
higher than their lowest common ancestor
anytime between any one of those two
notes because if you did that an RMP
would give you that node and not the
actual lowest common ancestor so the
reason for that is well it's pretty much
the same thing if they share some
ancestor you can't go and visit any
higher ancestors until you visited that
ancestors entire subtree so you have to
touch both of your query nodes as many
times as you're ever going to touch them
before you ever see anything above that
method that was quick is everyone cool
with that
all right I'm seeing a lot of time okay
so what's next well that's pretty much
it for at least for reducing lcao rmq
that's called a reduction we
take one problem and turn it into an
instance of the other one the only
tricky parts are well we gotta figure
out how fast we can do this because if
we're going to use our own cute solve
LCA we've got to be able to turn an LCA
problem into an RFQ problem in the back
got a fast enough so so is the
transformation from LCD to rmq that's
the yes that's the preprocessor so then
the theory is you're given two notes you
find you know any two instances of those
no so may as well take the first time
they appear but you can calculate as
you're doing you take any two instances
of those notes you do an arm Q query and
then that gives you the node you want it
so that a is the answer
so right so let's say arm q is this fast
this is pre-processing in query time how
fast is LCA if we use this and we just
say F and G are some function we're
going to assume as think about by
someone else
however long it takes you to generate
yeah so how long is that that
pre-processing time
yeah so the trick with the oil Ettore is
do it you're gonna traverse every edge
exactly twice and that makes this easy
to figure out so how many nodes are
there
well there's n nodes how many edges are
there in a tree of endnotes so minus 1
right so it hit every every edge twice
right and then the the root appears like
one extra time so it's minus 1 not minus
anyway so it takes so the Euler tour is
basically all the lanes 200 US 1 it
takes that that much time to get that
and it is it generates an array that
long so
right
pre-processing is create the array may
business
that's an extra constants but it's that
so it's great the array and then you are
in CUNY pre-processing on them and then
answer the query as you rightly pointed
out it's all the constant work turn it
into an RN q problem and then to get the
answer back out so it's order one has
some time plus whatever are on Q takes
hope and then this of course is just
ordered but that's the time for the
first very rather you only have to do
the
once so yeah both batteries the cost of
the car yeah so my notation here yeah so
my notation here is this kind of looks
like a dot product sort of product the
first element is pre-processing the
second home is and there's also you
could also put space in here but for
everything I'm going to say space is the
same as pre-processing anyway that's
that all we have left to do is so long
I'm cute okay someone shout out how we
could do that
how could be pre-processing array to
answer our own cue
and then we just call collapsing yeah
really really stupid easy before someone
said brute force that's the answer so
how do you pre-process a problem has a
finite input check all pairs yes so
we're gonna pre-processing this whole
thing every possible query and build a
big table
well I'm or easin this someone say how
long that takes
well if you got all pairs of them ten
elements that's going to be N squared
elements of the generate order and
squared but so so the simplest way to
generate all the pairs of answers how
long was that
so if we're just going to generate all
possible pairs of indexes for the for
the rmq problem and we want to just
compute all the answers up front and
storm on a table how fast can you do
that yep it turns out if you ask a
freshman to do this they'll tell you
what's your name it's program you can do
it right so I'm not a bit already got
this array I'm gonna generate a table
from this array it's gonna have maybe
the same number of things if this is n
then this is n 2 and so is this alright
so what's our table in the store well
along the top let's store the starting
index of the query
so if our queries are
that cleans that really if our queries
are from Ida J Anderson so if this is I
and this is these are in Exodus so I and
J then our range is this and our answer
can be any of these elements so along
the top we're going to put I so this is
I this from 0 to n so right and down
this side we're going to put J plus 1
minus I basically the width of the array
that we're looking at so I think it's
plus 1 if you want to be strict about it
so anyway so L is gonna be here so this
is the length of the array let's
actually just call it J minus on I guess
these are inclusive so zero here means
that it's just from eye to eye
okay so in this cell we're gonna put the
answer to the rnq that starts at zero
and goes to zero well let's let's
actually put some numbers in here I had
a smaller example so I'm going to do
that example over here
all right so here's our example they
were most of this reallocated too much
Margaret okay so well what's the
smallest number between position zero at
position zero great great except in here
we're going to put the index of the of
the answer so just get to why we want
the index later but it's not that big
from 1 to both sides of yourself from
one to one it's going to be well these
are all just going to be the same
indexes that they are because any
queries starting at some position and
going for mine farther is the answer at
that position
yeah so if you were yes yes that's why
that doesn't make any sense if you want
to shift everything down by N or by I it
works so what are we going to do now
well if we're a freshman we're going to
go here and we're going to say all right
what's the smallest thing between zero
that that starts at zero and goes one
more all right well it's one it's a
position one happens also be one
now what's the smallest thing that
starts at 1 and goes one farther well
also one and we're gonna continue doing
this and basically every time we fill in
one of these things we're gonna have to
do order and work and since there are n
squared of these that means we're doing
order and cubed work but we're smarter
than that working huge dynamic
programmer so how do we actually
calculate these well we look at the
things above for those of you that
haven't seen dynamic programming we're
looking at values we've already
calculated and figuring out new data
from that hmm so look at these these two
things up here I'm sorry the array that
starts at zero and goes one farther he's
gonna have a minimum that's well it's
the minimum of the array that starts at
zero and doesn't go anywhere else and
depending on if the array that starts at
one doesn't go anywhere else so I just
look at the things that are that are at
these locations and I write down leading
next to the smaller of those that's well
I already figured out that was one and
the same thing applies here so when I go
here I say all right the array that
starts at two and I was no farther that
had the answer of two right and the one
that started at three was the answer the
answer was the the element of three
which is 0
I say which one of those is smaller I
say okay it's zero so I write that down
I write down its index
and the same thing can last one so that
we're super not clear because we're
starting out with the race that didn't
go anywhere else so now where it gets
interesting as we have some overlap so
here we want the array that starts at
zero it goes too far that when I already
know the answers for the arrays for this
array and for this erect so I can take
the minimum of those two answers and
then do the same thing so that's one and
I'm going to continue filling this out
so now
so now my query is this won't answer
I'll fill in this box but I already know
these two well this one's minimum
element is 1
this one's been in the melon element at
0 0 is less than 1 so I want this one
which is at position 3 so I write down 3
and that's kind of the first interesting
data point this particular example and I
continue filling this out and I actually
end up with this and now now I basically
filled out every possible query I can
throw out this Iraq and so now to answer
the query it's pretty easy I just go and
look up the the element that I wanted so
I went through flow through that because
I don't know if everyone's seen dynamic
programming if you haven't please let me
know if anything wasn't clear very
useful technique anyway
right so now I've got this thing so how
fast I say well I had to fill out you
know n times n over two things which is
1/2 and Squared's that's order and
square but then my queries are just like
subtract I from J and then I look up
some element in a matrix that's constant
time so that's nice
so we did it it's we're in squared
pre-processing order one for your time
well that I wouldn't have written so
what else can we do what can we do
that's less expensive yeah
what's fun about trees right so if logs
let's try logs
let's get rid of this off so let's get
rid of this extra crap reallocated
how can we use logs
structure the structure of what it's a
tree the 200
right there you have N squared possible
queries
so what could we do that's less
expensive than filling out every
possible extra right okay so you can
have sort of something like order one
pretty cross over
it's very processing and that some
amortized crap here it's not going to be
like that it's gonna be totally
constructive we're going to do it right
the first time and they're gonna answer
all our equations right about the
translation
let's just assume so right now I'm just
trying to solve rlq all right I'm
wondering if you can do something where
like for each element you keep track of
the element to its left that is smaller
than yeah you could do that
just leaving you guys on the right track
all right well so what problem with this
is we tried to write down every answer
right let's try to write down less than
that because there are n squared
questions and we can't do better than
that write them all down so we were
trying to write down every what was it
every answer that starts at every
possible index and is of any possible
way well I told you about logs so let's
just try only links that are powers of
two so what do we do here don't know why
I keep doing this
so instead of this y-axis here being the
length of the query array let's say this
is the log of that way or equivalently
not say this is the ones that are well
let's still have this zero one
let's have ones that are zero length of
one length of two lengths and then maybe
of four this will go all the way down
here
or if you want to keep this as three you
can do some logs it's an attraction that
works so okay so what's the smallest
thing for getting tired of saying this
but a raise that start at zero and our
flame
why well that's that's gonna be a
position one again actually this one we
already filled out this is one one four
three three two
I actually already filled that one out
too this is not a super interesting is
that Boulder Oh guess not really
the array that starts at zero and
there's a blink for is this okay
we know the answer here which is this
one we know the answer here which is
this one so let's just take the minimum
of those two right oh that's gonna be a
position three and the same thing for
this one here Joseph
sorry you guys didn't check my back
that's one sir so then the array that
starts at one and is for long it's gonna
be this array and this array this one
has an answer of index one this one has
an answer if index three and index 3 is
smaller so we're gonna go write down 3
cool
well now we're done so if we go up to 8
we can't fit that query in our array so
we're done reprocessing and if every
time we go down the level our
precomputing answer queries are getting
twice as big and they stop at the size
of the problem
well how many levels do we have here
someone shout out
yes one river one space the one one
really want like one yogurt two things
blank my like two or three things one
the 4 over 5 sorry these are or I'm
having trouble explaining this right
because we're mixing up inclusive and
exclusive so this this linked here this
- yeah means basically you know if this
is index 0 1 2 2 3 4 a raise of link to
our where 3 minus 1 is 2 but there's
actually three elements there because
the last one was inclusive I'm just
having that type of notation right so
oh yeah you're right sorry there's only
one thing here you're absolutely right
my mistake this one goes all the way out
here this is just a bad example son as
much very why I just said sorry that was
very confusing
these numbers are confusing the point is
every time every time you go down a
level the answer you're pre-computing
the rate gets twice as big and so this
has height log n you still this top one
has n elements
you can play this pain stunt with the
where the off that start and only do you
know you know to to the I do you know
queries of form to to the I of links to
to the I that start on an index to the
you might be able to do that but we
haven't finished with this one yet you
guys we have to figure out how to answer
queries with us and then we can talk
about that okay so how do you go that's
our grants with us
either you confess - happy birthday
I think you have to do work a slogan
so I'm so which lookups you need it
because I mean Eve each to you would
need to go you can't include stuff
that's not so let's say I have a links
of seven just a throw a number out there
I have to do the link or yeah so you can
do log increase with us where you you
know take all the let's say your query
you might have your array like yes so
when you're imagining is a scenario like
this where you only do you only
pre-process queries that begin at a
power of two index and that was what
you're suggesting that requires you to
do a log down below cups so the answer
for everyone who wasn't in either of our
two lines it is that to perform the
query you've got the answer to all
queries of sizes that are a power of two
that started this index so if you're if
you're you know actual query starts at
this index what you're going to do is
pick the largest power of two that's
smaller than your query so just to make
this interesting
this is a it's so fast let's say we want
to answer this disarray
well we've got all powers of two that
start here namely we've got see one two
three four we've got that one which is
the biggest power of two that fits in
this array I'm sorry that it's a power
of two plus one by indexing it's totally
screwed the other thing we want to look
up is the one that is the same size but
pushed all the way to the other side
here so we're gonna look up we just take
the min of those two and it's okay that
they overlap because we want the minimum
over all that's fine so if we compute if
we pre compute all arrays the art of
power of juice size will always be able
to find two of them that overlap a
little bit and our their union is equal
to our actual query and maybe they
overlap a little bit but who cares
and then I'll go outside and
the minimum of the answers to those two
problems will be the actual answer we
want our indexing was really messed up
again sorry about that
is that does that start to become clear
terrible and so the same basically the
same dynamic programming trick of saying
well you know to compute this we take
this one this one to be at this we take
this one on this one that same trick
works and so it's really just the time
to fill out this matrix right so you
don't so when you're when you're filling
this one out
you don't use these two you use these
two to generate this you have to get yes
that's right that works so how big is
this again yes so this is the sparse rmq
and it is not a one and amortized crap
it's something else
pre-processing in this order
and queries are oh it's to look up so
it's harder one cool
so the original LCA was something like
order n plus two sorry
it was order n plus this function of 2 n
minus 1 and then the query was order 1
plus that's that's still order 1 this
function of 2 n minus 1 is still order n
log n which is bigger than order n so
that we can solve the same LCA problem
in a mug and pre-processing in order 1
great time faster all right so that's
first table now to move on we need to
notice something about the array that
we're generating from LCA we're giving
we're gonna find that it has a certain
restriction and then we're going to use
that restriction to get a better
algorithm with your time
so I have two and a half tricks left to
show you and let's see if I can do it in
20 minutes all right so what is the
special property of arrays that are
generated from an Euler tour of the tree
what's interesting about that you
remember it was the level array the
depths of the notes that we don't care
about for the our key problem what's
interesting about that array
absolutely nothing interesting let's
charge forward so what's that oh but
that's not that's a property of the
treating out of the array so let's
charge forward anyway so here's a cool
trick we have a plug-in algorithm right
we've got this array of size I said cool
let's chop it up specifically we're
going to chop it up into segments of
size log in over to so this is log
number two is this log on over to this
and so on
okay how many of those are there
n over 2 over n it's two men over
lugging
all right so we've got those all right
put that with that
right let's chew a little again
sweet alright I don't walk around all
right so from taking the log of a
Division I can subtract them a little
bit order things that goes well they
used to kill each other and that's a
minus sign so I don't care about that
that's tiny anyway that's nice all right
how do I do that well I break it up into
these sub arrays I get this nice little
expression which makes my writing time
go down to order so what can I do with
these sets
I can compute there there many ways so I
can from this array I can compute one
minimum and I can also know where it is
on your right that's fine you do the
same for this one this one this one this
one cool
I have an array of that size which means
because I can solve that problem with
order and the preprocessor okay so this
is the these are these sub arrays and so
if I pick so what does this actually
give oh if I pick two of these sub
arrays it means that I can find the
minimum element in all of them with
processing order
all right but my query just don't line
up exactly with these so how can I use
that to solve the original RFQ problem
I'm sorry basically I'm saying all right
so I've got this array this is gonna be
a crime sure a prime is going to be the
minima of each of these sub arrays okay
and a prime has signs to an overlap
because I happen to choose that the
separation website's log K over 2 okay
that's our fire yeah so now I say all
right now I'm going to pre-process a
prime for our on the Q queries okay
you're going to the build it or no
you're gonna go the the triangle um yeah
so I'm gonna use the sparse table rnq
answer and I'm gonna say I'm gonna run
this n log n pre-processing algorithm on
an array of size 2 I - Wacha nice ok
bingo so that's it but now you have you
have a subproblem that's not exactly the
full problems how do you go one on the
subproblem we don't get used you said
that in some way so I maybe I missed
that step
sorry I just so yeah so this the RM
queue data structure on a prime lets us
answer queries where I and J fall
exactly on these boundaries we've chosen
that make sense yep
so now the question is if I can answer
those questions with order and
pre-processing and order one query how
do I solve general rmq problems where
these indexes might not lie exactly on
these boundaries the answer is well do
this do this crazy thing on everything
in between your indexes and then you've
only got to solve it in two places
let's say this is your actual query you
solve it with a prime on me on this
middle part now they just have to solve
it on these small little things so
another question is alright well how do
i how do i pre process all of these
little segments so that they can answer
these little berries and do all the
pre-processing for all of the segments
in order anity so they can all be fast
right so if I can do this queries under
one this query can order one this query
another one but I can just miss them on
any of those sub queries where one of
the boundaries is the edge of a sub
array yeah so what I really need to do
is I need to pre-process each son
rightful sub arrays that are of size log
n over two
to get
then you just use what however we're
going to answer this to answer that
query you you have the full panel the
full sparks table for that summer thing
so if it's just within a single suburb
or separate you just answer it's only
when you're crossing boundaries so if I
just pre-processed every single one of
these using the sparse table that would
still take too long so I need to do I
need to do something to make that take
less time well maybe some of these sub
arrays are basically the same so back to
my earlier question what's interesting
about the rmq arrays that come from the
LC a problem
they're not quite - but you're on the
right track but more interesting on my
money we're talking about I thought you
were talking about a property of a boy a
little walk and the property to the oil
walk issue and we have an increment plus
one between every index yes it's it's
the property of the array that you get
when you take an LC a problem and turn
it into a by doing a tour and that
property is that neighboring elements
differ only by plus or minus one they
don't differ by zero they don't differ
by two just plus or minus 1 that's what
gives you're going up and down this tree
if that's your generating which means
that each one of these little sub arrays
is either you know each every time I
cross one of these lines I go up or down
one so what's next well let's say this
one is like zero one two one two let's
say this one is three four five four
five what's interesting about this
what's up you know what have you been
treated water yeah that's the same shape
so if you take sure this array and you
normalize it by just saying well you
know if I'm going to do an autocue query
on these two nodes that's going to give
me the same position within this array
as an arm cube query on these two nodes
because they go up and down in the same
pattern so they're they're structurally
similar and so really you can normalize
this and just subtract 3 all the way
across and you get awesome alright so if
you pre-process in this array then you
come across this one and say all right I
need to pre-process back say ah well
it's going to have the same structure as
this so I can just use the same already
pre-process structure so how many of
these are there
oh sorry how many distinct subarrays how
many subarrays of this size are there
with different shapes yes okay well this
is that square root so there's possible
different subtypes
oh sorry sir teacher please
so each of these positions is either
going to be basically plus or minus one
different from the previous so you can
think of these as bits so zero means go
down and a 1 means come up and so when
you represent an array like this as soon
as a fit vector you and you get this
many possible vectors of length how many
possible ones yeah so there's you don't
necessarily have to have all of them but
there's basically route and possible
ones
so just to divide the exponent there is
if you eat encode each one is a bit the
exponent is that's the size of each
summary so yeah okay so that's nice but
doesn't really get us anywhere
how do we pre process root end of these
things in order in time wait a minute
that's not too hard right
is your end any images and they're all
of length login over to make sure this
with the naive one right we're done
times pre-processing this one million
squared algorithm o log squared n is
less than we're done so if we multiply
them that's certainly going to be less
than brunette times for them which is
and so that's a much less than order and
preprocessor we're done all right so
what we actually doing here some things
this is a chemist somewhere freaking out
so now that I've lost everyone what does
we actually do well we realized that our
array has this weird shape where each
element only differs from the last one
by plus or minus one now we did this
cool trick where we took our whole array
we divided it into roughly and over log
n sub arrays and then we solved a
problem of size n over log n with a
solution that takes and times log n time
but when you plug this into this you get
order
and then we use the solution to the
broken up problem together with
solutions to all of these small problems
that we were able to compute in
significantly less than a grand time and
now we're able to answer any query by
saying alright well I'm gonna take the
beginning little part of it here and use
one of these sub array naive data
structures as I compute it and I'm going
to do the same thing on the on the end
and in the middle of them use this big
fancy thing I've constructed and because
I happen to be able to solve all these
smaller problems in order n time atotal
and combine the results of all the
answers in constant time I'm left with a
data structure that is
look through the data structure answers
these plus or minus 1 range military
problems in time which is just toddler
texture at the end so that's cool we
can't go any farther
ok we have to read all the all the input
that takes at least order n time and we
have to do something to give us answers
that's as good as we can get our I'm
cute and our original LCA problem why is
anyone on that
I was the LCA bound Oh F here's order
ends that's until order ends that's our
current Donny G here just constant that
bar two minutes let's go that's all
general so we solved plus or minus one
arm we saw the constrained problem that
we get from doing we have a general
problem mark you right we have this that
doesn't have that plus or minus one
property so we can't unify all those sub
arrays into the same naive data
structure so we're screwed let's turn
into LC yeah so how do we do this
they're gonna construct a Cartesian
trade a Cartesian Cherie is a heap a
partition tree of an array is a heap of
the elements in the array so parents are
smaller than their children which makes
sense and in order traversal
is the original input so it's a it's a
tree which allows it to be a heap and it
allows them to have an inorder traversal
and the inorder traversal is going to be
there right so how do we do this well
does it come to you since reconstruction
which takes order n time I'm gonna go
through really quickly basically we're
gonna do is for each element
you're gonna go along you're gonna make
a new tree node that's not so we write
down three that's our route say alright
five is bigger than three so it's got to
go below three but it's also going to go
to the right because the owner order
property right child now they have eight
it's gotta go below three it's never
double of five instead of be to the
right emotion hundred so there it is
minus one smaller than all of these but
it's got to be to the right of all we
have a new group and six is smaller than
that so this X goes down here and 27
goes down here cool
you can do this order in time ask me how
at the bar basically you're going to
keep track of the rightmost sort of the
leg lowest element you just added and if
the new thing so let's say we didn't
have this part so if you just got three
five and eight we just had an eight we
want to add minus one
well minus 1 is smaller than 8 so we
can't put it there you've got to put it
above it's alright is it smaller than 5
yep that's smaller than 3 yep alright
time to make a new root if it were let's
say 6 then we would move this down put 6
here and do that and now we've still got
a heap property and we still got 8 to
the right of 5 and to the left
and that's kind of how you do that now
if I pick any two notes let's say three
and six they're in order so they're you
know at those points we solved the LCA
problem on that tree and we get the
answer at minus one look that's the
smallest thing in that grade sorry I had
to go through that part so fast but
that's kind of where it all comes
together you turn an LCA and RFQ and
then you turn army came back into LCA
and everything solves itself someone
here said it was fractal you're right
anyway that's that time but I hope y'all
have fun ask me questions later I think
there's some really cool stuff in here
you know reducing one problem to another
is really interesting technique dynamic
programming is a great technique this
trick of taking a lot an n log n
algorithm and solving a broken up
problem of size n over log N and then
solving the smaller problems in a
simpler way that comes up a lot comes up
in and I think exponential trees
definitely comes up in Y fast trees it's
a really really useful technique for
sneaking like the last little bit of fun
for them anyway
[Music]
[Applause]